good morning everyone those of you
watching at home may be wondering
why this meeting hasn't started it being
a rainy day and a Monday we seem to be
lagging in attendance somewhat so we're
going to wait a few minutes to see if we
get a little more attendance plus we're
waiting on an amendment from OLS both of
those things
will cause us to have to wait a little
while before we get started
I'll try to keep you up to date as
to update you watching at home
we are going to start this meeting as
soon as we receive an amendment from OLS
that is the hold up this morning and we
really can't discuss anything until we
have an amendment to discuss so we're
waiting for that uh
we've got people working on it and hope
to have something soon
are you watching at home and for late
arrivals here we're waiting for for an
amendment from OLS that is the hold up
here this morning we will begin this
meeting as soon as we have something to
discuss
at the moment we do not have anything to
discuss so we appreciate your patience
we'll get you some information as soon
foreign
okay ladies and gentlemen your attention
please
we have an amendment
and so I would like to start this
meeting
albeit belatedly 9 25 scheduled for nine
o'clock I apologize for that but we had
to wait until we had something to
discuss before we could
open the meeting and commence the
discussion
so the first thing we'll do as usual is
we'll all rise and join representative
Bernardi as eligious in the Pledge of
Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
right
the sun is out so it's no longer a rainy
day and a Monday it's still a Monday but
all right so before we get
going on this this morning I want to
outline what the day will look like
the first activity of this morning
session will be for the
subcommittee the SB 54 subcommittee to
vote on its recommendation to the full
committee
after we take that vote we will then
open
a full committee work session on
the subcommittee's recommendation which
includes a significant Amendment
we'll discuss that Amendment as long as
necessary
once we've exhausted our comments and
discussion on the amendment
we will
end the full committee work session
and
conclude our mornings work
then we'll come back here at two o'clock
this afternoon for an executive session
on Senate bill 54.
both the majority caucus and the
minority caucus will probably have
I know that's true of the majority
carcass
so this room will be unavailable
starting at one o'clock
until about
130 maybe 20 minutes of two
so with that as as way of by way of
background we can now begin the formal
activity of the day
and as chair of the SB 54 subcommittee
I'm going to call for a vote
from the subcommittee members
on a recommendation to the full
committee that we passed Senate bill 54.
by adopting Amendment
and I would ask are there any is there a
need for any further discussion from the
subcommittee members
representative McGee
yeah I'm I don't see that uh Amendment
here you passed it out right
you didn't get a copy oh it does have
1580h is the
we're going to have a full discussion on
the amendment in a moment
um
I I have a question that representative
muns brought up to me
um on
it's section
eight in the old Amendment and I'm not
sure let me see if I can find it here
it's in this section
on
um for the purpose of this section new
electric energy sources are those that
are able to provide additional energy to
the iso New England regional market
and the date in there is January 1st
um
and that there are energy sources that
existed prior to January 1st 2023 and
the question is why it set
um
in the past and why it wouldn't be set
for say 2025 to be starting in the
future
so you're talking about line 16 on page
yeah it starts on 16. ends on 19. yep
all right I would suggest that since
representative munz is a member of the
full committee but not a member of the
subcommittee that we take up his
question
when we begin the full committee work
session would that be acceptable
yeah
is there any further discussion then
from the subcommittee members
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
chairman
um I'm going to be slightly pedantic if
you'll indulge my pedanticism for a
moment I'm looking at page two line
eight
and
the word only is misplaced in that
sentence
because the word only modifies what
should modify only what immediately
follows it
so I'd really like to see the word only
moved from where it is to to be between
the words for and up so it would say
we'll be eligible for approval for only
up to a total not to exceed
that would be more precise language and
since this is legal language it should
that suggestion I'm trying to evaluate
whether I think it's
so
right now the the word only is uh the
second word on the line says will only
be eligible which
based on the true meaning of of only and
where it is in the sentence this is
saying that
there's only one thing about the
agreements that are true and it's this
eligible nothing else about the
agreements is true
and I'm suggesting that it be moved to
between the words four and up so it'd be
will be eligible for approval for only
up to so that we're actually restricting
the right thing which is the amount of
power
I used to teach writing I used to direct
the writing program at Dartmouth so I I
get pedantic about these things but you
know because this is legal language we
should be getting it right
so you are correct this is a split
infinitive in in language terms and it's
a common split infinitive
but um
but I don't know that we need to make a
change it seems to me that it's not
it's not vague it may not be precise in
terms of legal language but as I said
I'm being pedantic but you know I I do
like to get these things right okay
well if we decide that we need to make
other changes maybe we'll make that one
the chair may ask for clarification yes
so
on the interpretation going back to the
pedantics
on the interpretation would
could one be could the prior the way it
is currently will only be eligible for
approval for up to a total not to exceed
could that be
um
interpreted differently than the
language that you're suggesting in terms
so that question is for representative
yeah I mean it it could be right because
we're saying agreements will only be
eligible you know Etc
so you know only modifies what
immediately follows it so what we're
saying is
there's only one thing about the
agreements that's true and it's that
they're eligible for approval blah blah
blah
and nothing else about the agreements is
okay
we're restricting the agreements to only
being eligible for approval and nothing
else about the agreements is okay the
only thing that they're allowed to do is
be eligible for approval up to 2 million
megawatt hours
whereas what we really want to be
restricting isn't everything about the
so doesn't that come back to what the
intent of the sentence is yeah and it
starts with collectively among all
investor-owned electric distribution
utilities so collectively agreements
will be eligible for approval for only
up to
that's right a total not to exceed right
yeah so it's it's
it more clearly states the intent right
if it's edited right yeah I would agree
right and again you know again I admit
I'm being pedantic but and and I agree
with our our chair if we make further
changes that would be a good change to
make if we're not making further changes
might not be worth it
okay I appreciate that
further comments from the subcommittee
on the question of whether we're going
to prop propose to the full committee
representative Gorman thank you Mr
chairman
um I actually want to revisit something
I brought up last week and that is on
lines again page two lines 16 through
18.
and this is
what incremental electric energy sources
are
because the way the wording is right now
it says that they are those that existed
prior to January 1 2023
and which as a result of new
construction are capable of providing
additional energy into the iso New
England regional market on or after
the way I read that I I see that you
could have a power generator that
existed before January 123.
let's say just to make some numbers it's
producing 100 megawatts
and then it's added on to after January
123 let's say it's another 10 megawatts
again just to make numbers
the way I interpret this the entire 110
megawatts would be
eligible
right because the the
Source existed before January 1 as a
result of new construction it is capable
of providing additional energy
okay so that's the 110. it's not the
incremental part it's it's the
additional energy I think that's the
intention here
okay
representative Bernardi
yes I I mean I have read this and and I
I don't have that concern I see it's
only the 10 not the the hundred that it
would be eligible because
uh it is the are capable of providing
additional energy so it's the additional
that's relevant that's how I read it but
I I understand how you can interpret it
differently
what would you do to rewrite this
well we actually did get suggested
wording
um
and let me find that
uh so we could say incremental electric
energy sources are the new and
additional resources which as a result
of new construction at sites where
energy facilities existed prior to
January 1 2023 are able to be provided
into the iso New England regional market
for the first time on or after January 1
2023. so it's the new and additional
resources part that I think is relevant
here
maybe it's as simple as putting in
another sentence that says incremental
uh energy resources shall be limited to
the new the whatever we've got here is
new new resources and not previously uh
built ones or whatever something like
that I think it needs to be changed it's
too easy I mean but when you see Brooke
as an example they put out 1200
megawatts it would not take a hell of a
lot for him to put out 1205 megawatts
and then if someone could read this to
say all of that then would be eligible
and I think it needs to be clarified
because uh I mean it's just it's
okay this does seem like a legitimate
issue to
consider
Mr chairman maybe it's as simple as
saying only the additional energy
provided to the iso regional market will
be eligible for the contract
only the additional incremental energy
sources
would be so eligible
only the additional incremental energy
well we're talking about the interim
incremental Electric
so Mr chairman I I think the section is
defining what incremental
or new electric energy sources including
incremental means right
so what I think what you're suggesting
or what representative Harrington
suggested about adding a sentence to say
contracts will be limited to new and
additional electrical resources added to
the New England the iso New England
regional market that kind of thing like
a clarifying statement on the end
is more about the contract piece whereas
the I think the letter B is actually
just trying to Define what we mean by
new and incremental so
are we going to now try and do both in
that section
which I I don't I don't have any problem
with I'm just saying
um if we Define it properly we may not
need to say the other part no you're
right the whole purpose of this
paragraph As the first sentence stage
says for the purposes of this section
new electric energy sources
are and then
incremental electric energy sources are
so it's the purpose of this paragraph is
to design what those Define what those
two things are
so you're right
um
what we need to do is just clarify the
definition
but I can give you the suggested wording
again if you'd like to hear it okay go
ahead okay so it would be incremental
electric energy sources
are the new and additional resources
comma
which as a result of new construction at
sites where energy facilities existed
prior to January 1 2023
comma are able to be provided into the
iso any regional market
for the first time on or after January 1
2023 and now I said that a little faster
than you you did right yeah I couldn't
John would you turn on your microphone
okay it's on representative Colon's
computer and he could just uh blast it
off to all of us yeah I mean I could
why don't you do that we'll do send a
quick email to all of us and we'll
while representative Corman is doing
that
does anybody else on the subcommittee
representative Bernardi you okay with
everything
um I'm looking I'm trying to contrast
you'll have to forgive the quiet while
yes there are other copies around
somewhere
Mr chair on page three line 15 letter B
this time it actually is a b because my
eyes
um
I'm sure yeah
I'm assuming since the one before it's
an a not a g
um it says credit or charge all
distribution rate payers
um
should we modify that to say of the
Contracting utility so that it's a
it's specific to distribution rate
payers of the per the group that's
creating the PPA is that a modification
maybe should have in language I don't
think so because the the paragraph
starting on line eight
specifically points out that
requires the electric distribution
utility
to take these actions
so
I don't think
okay
you think it's covered is that what
well when it says all distribution rate
payers
if it doesn't say of that company or of
the Contracting utility then wouldn't
that legally maybe include all people
who are paying distribution charges I
mean there probably wouldn't be any way
contractually to
charge them but it wouldn't be excluded
or precluded with the language that's
here
Mr chairman maybe go ahead
representative Harrington is just adding
it there credit or charge all their
distribution rate payers and then it
would be clear that you're talking about
the electric distribution utility that's
mentioned above
we just had that word I think that would
representative McGee can you tell us
does this amendment
repo what does this amendment replace in
the existing bill
okay it appears to be that yeah it's
it's an entire replace however
um
I have a copy of what was submitted to
OLS in terms of the bolded sections that
were adopted by the various stakeholders
who presented language to us for
consideration
so the first section uh that was changed
was
I don't have the same number so it'll be
I have to
I'm telling you the right place so
okay
um
of the amendment yeah
I'm looking for it the numbers are
different so it's going to make it even
more challenging
it's the section that starts electric
distribution utilities
let's see
um
no I'm sorry
that's not it this is a lot harder than
it's the electric distribution utilities
shall consult with the Department of
energy and the office of the consumer
Advocate on all issues related to such
page one line 27. that's right yep it is
page one
so after the word
proposals
the added part is from line 19 the
department in the office of the consumer
Advocate shall provide any such
consultation within 60 days from the
date each draft request for proposals is
provided for its review within this
period the utilities May solicit public
comment
and I thought we had changed that to
Shell but
it somehow still says May
yeah my copy says shell and they
they put it in as May so I'm not sure
what happened there
but that was where we thought the public
comment would be appropriate
so I would like to see that be shall on
line 21 rather than May
and then the next section
of energy May hire Consultants to Aid in
the development of requests for
proposals and assess the costs of such
Consultants to the relevant distribution
electric utility or utilities as
appropriate and Equitable on a
case-by-case basis the department shall
not enter into any contract under this
section in an amount greater than ten
thousand dollars including the any
contract extension without the approval
and then section e
um
let's see
section section e was also a bolded
section that we sent for inclusion which
was electric distribution utilities
shall engage and independent third party
to create appropriate requests for
proposal and to perform cost-benefit
analysis of any agreement received
in response to the request for proposals
such analysis shall be provided to the
commission as part of the utilities
petition for approval of any purchase
power agreement resulting from the RFP
process
so
so section two of the Bill of the
amendment is this basically the
substance of the bill because section
one was just fine that's correct yep
so I have a question about those two
paragraphs go ahead um so
the with the wording that representative
McGee
suggests
um it's that the
uh where am I here the the department of
energy May hire Consultants
but the electric distribution utilities
shall engage an independent third party
right right so is that what what we
really intend here that that the
utilities have to have an independent
third party
yeah we had the conversation
um last Monday okay about what it means
to have someone other than the utilities
doing their own
um review and also
um
the idea that that person would be
providing an objective cost-benefit
analysis that would be used by the puc
that's in later language so
um yeah I think there was agreement that
that would be a good thing
that is my memory okay
with regard to your suggestion that on
where it says the utilities May solicit
public comment I think you suggested
that
that should be changed to shall solicit
public comment my recollection of our
May would be
preferable because it doesn't it
wouldn't slow down the process if if we
change that to Shell soliciting public
comment could take quite a long time and
slow down the process significantly
and since this whole
the whole purpose of Senate Bill 54 is
to get these ppeas in place by 2026 as I
recall
um
I don't know that we want to do anything
that could slow the process down
so I would recommend that we leave that
as the utilities May solicit public
comment
well Mr chair respectfully it does say
within this period so it's a confined
period that's in use already
um you know so it's a finite period it
won't be any longer than the 60 days
that's I think that's the point so what
would happen if the utilities were
required to solicit public comment
within that 60-day period
but it did not arrive with the 60-day
period expire without public comment or
with the 60-day period be extended
I think changing that may to a shell
would impose conditions on that 60-day
well I think the reason it was put in
there was the concern for there being an
ability for public comment on what will
be substantially new and different and
large contracts that if there is no um
you know if there is no explicit request
that there be public comment than where
where does the public fit into something
that they are going to have to pay for
foreign
representative Harrington thank you um I
I understand what you're saying chairman
but I don't think it makes a difference
whether it's a May or a shell you still
get the same problem if they may and
let's say the utility decides to go out
for public comment and a couple show up
but then they start getting them after
the 60-day
period it's the same issue as if they
shall do it it doesn't change it one way
or the other that way if it's if there's
a concern about that uh you could put uh
period utilities shout solicit public
comment uh
all comments must be received within the
60-day notice and then that takes care
of the ongoing problem so it's clear
that if someone delivers a I won't look
at someone like Clifton over there but
he delivers a book 62 days later you're
okay
I don't feel strongly about that to be
honest with you
I'm okay with changing that made to a
the doe there still
line 22
the department of energy May hire
Consultants
you want to change that to a shell too I
don't what if the department doesn't
need to hire a consultant I don't know
I think that should stay a May
I'm okay with that as long as the
the utilities have theirs as a shell
and then there's
um two more bolded changes that I'll
refer us to and again the numbers don't
call inside so let me figure out what
it's in section three
that rolls onto page three
contains rate payer protections which
may include such mechanisms as
performance incentives stop loss caps
penalties for non-performance or others
as proposed by the utility and
determined by the commission to be
adequate
and then okay before you move on
um
one of the commenters
on this language suggested that stop
are not an appropriate
um
ratepayer protection mechanism
recent experience with stop loss caps
has not been particularly positive
so I would Advocate if we're going to be
making changes anyway let's remove
the words stop loss caps from that
sentence Mr chair I believe that
language came from doe so I put it in
exactly as they asked and what my
question would be is what is stop loss
caps intended to help protect people
from us there's some other term that
would be suitable to capture it or
I think it's this language was intended
to capture the mechanism that's in the
Burgess PPA
the cumulative reduction Factor stop
loss cap
and I don't think even though this
language originally was proposed by the
DOE I don't think that they would object
to the removal of that
phrase and I believe one or more of the
utilities would prefer the removal of
that phrase so if we're going to change
it anyway I think we should remove that
phrase
may I just ask a question about that
there was there was also language that
the New England
um power generators Association had
recommended along these lines talking
about creating
um a dollar a dollar cap for I think it
was 100 million that they had in there
that and I'm not sure I'm no expert on
any of this I'm not sure how that would
help or not but I guess the question
would be
um
are there any protections that are going
to be written into Statute in terms of
the type of loss cap that would be
sustained by ratepayers since our intent
is to make sure that they
are have stabilized rates and or lower
rates but not to be
um you know having a having a burden
to answer your question I would think
that the 100 million dollar
reference suggested by the any PGA
would be virtually identical to a
stopwatch stop loss cap so uh
I think that the current language which
suggests mechanisms such as performance
incentives and penalties for
non-performance
those would really be the mechanisms
that you would use to
provide rate payer protections I don't
know that there are others
that this legislation needs to specify
it does say or others as proposed by the
utility and determined by the commission
to be adequate so if there are any other
right payer protections That Could Be
Imagined and proposed then they could be
considered
yes okay right
representative Harrington yeah this um
this whole paragraph is kind of uh
difficult because
um it talks about performance incentives
stop-loss caps penalties for
non-performance I assume the penalties
for non-performance would be uh to the
supplier not to the utility because the
utility is going to sign a contract in
that's basically the end of the story
for them they're signing a contract with
X supplier and sold the penalty for that
is I'm guessing if it's that cold winter
day and X supplier doesn't Supply
whatever Mega watch they were supposed
to supply they Supply less then there's
going to be a something in the contract
that would punish them they would have
to pay a fine or something like that is
that what we're talking about here
and the stop loss cap issue
um to me
we're trying to predict the future which
we know we can't do very well all you
have to do is go back to last two the
last two Winters
um we thought prices were going to be
much lower two Winters ago and all the
suppliers lost a lot of money when it
came in much higher and then this last
winter everyone thought prices were
going to be much much higher than they
actually were I mean the death month was
supposed to be January we averaged fifty
dollars uh the LMP was fifty dollars a
megawatt hour much lower than everybody
thought so we were off then and now
we're looking 20 years into the future
so I don't see how you can reasonably
put in a stock loss thing because
someone's going to look at that if I'm A
supplier I'm going to look at that and
say
you want me to sign a contract I'll sign
the contract here's what I can live with
for a price but don't tell me if the
market rates go down substantially that
I'm going to get penalized because
otherwise I'm outside of the contract
so except something to think about well
I think the the I just would say in
response that it does say which may
include these types of mechanisms so
it's just sort of listing uh potential
mechanisms but it's not imposing any so
and the other thing I would say is
they're determined to be adequate what
is that doesn't really say anything uh
determined to be in the best interest of
rate payers I would change that adequate
to best interest of rate payers it gives
the puc a little bit more defined I mean
adequate is kind of I mean almost a
meaningless term in that situation
and
F goes into that stuff like a catch-all
you can get rid of everything else and
just put in
factors necessary to determine whether
the agreement is just and reasonable in
the public interest I mean that covers
everything
so I'm not sure if we want to be
specific about it
we don't want that in there if we don't
want to be specific about it you can
take everything else out and just put
that in
but it seems to be this seems to be you
know uh Belton suspenders here we get
two sets of criteria you're supposed to
do all of this but if there's another
factor that puc determines is just and
reasonable and in the public interest
then they don't have to necessarily go
along with the other factors above it
it's just it kind of puts them in a
situation where
there's really no specific guidance
because they can do whatever they feel
is just unreasonable
so so why don't we just delete the words
to be adequate just in that sentence
I I would again I would add by the
commission to be in the best interest of
the rate payers
because that's what we're trying to tell
them that's that's the message we're
sending all along here the best news is
the rate pays could be a good Supply in
the winter time maybe it's a higher
price but it's reliable energy it could
also be a lower price contract so that I
think that covers
okay change to be adequate to be to be
in the best interest of rate bears
all right it's okay with me looks like
we're going to be making quite a few
changes representative Gorman good that
means we can move only in that sentence
uh so uh representative munz brought
something to my attention and I'm
looking at page two the last two lines
about the long duration winter cold
event
and
the point that representative Munns made
to me was that that's not the only type
of weather event that could stress the
grid and a supplier right for example a
very hot day
where we need a lot of power
or some other weather related event and
I'm wondering should it just be
restricted to these long duration winter
cold events which we know those were
issues recently but we could just as
easily have a long duration summer heat
event
comment representative Harrington yeah I
mean obviously we could have a long hot
spell in the in the summertime but the
Dynamics of the market change so much
because you're not dealing with heating
sources and all the ldcs are basically
selling all the pipeline space that
they've contracted into the market for
gas fire generators to use so there's
virtually no limit I mean if we could go
to 100 of all gas fire generators and
they wouldn't run out of gas like they
do in the winter time you're also going
to maximize your solar output during
those months as well and the solar gets
more and more that's going to be a
bigger Factor but so I think that
putting this there is is a good idea but
I think it needs to be rewarded be
worded slightly it says supports
electric energy sources the soap
supports it's doesn't say anything about
producing electricity so if we have a
source that produces during The Long
Winter durations it's just as important
supports tells me it's like transmission
okay so are we going to have we're going
to bring trans more transmission so you
can get more power from one place to the
other place but I think we should have
you know supports electric energy
supports electric generation or support
of electric energy sources that are
expected to be available during the long
duration winter cold events so it covers
both of those because right now you can
make the case that you don't take in
account New Generation you just account
you're saying generation or support I I
guess would be creates or supports
energy
electric energy sources that are
expected to be available during a long
consider whether each agreement is on
balance substantially consistent with
now
yeah just say it just create your
before
so creates or supports electric energy
sources
so Mr chair there is one more
highlighted section that got changed
which is on page three and it's Section
5 was inserted and the former Section 5
was numbered six Roman numeral six so
five is to the extent any proposed
agreement
to purchase electrical to purchase
electric energy includes environmental
attributes such as renewable energy
credits the Public Utilities Commission
shall approve how such environmental
attributes are used or disposed of in a
manner expected to minimize costs and
thank you
would you like to turn on your mic and
tell us about that
right
so going back to uh page two the January
1st 2023 an incremental electric energy
sources trying to make this simple
um
so
incremental energy sources are
break everything up to the word result
and replace it with only the
and then keep result of new construction
strike the comma and the word are
capable of providing additional energy
to the iso New England
regional market on or after
January 1 2023.
I think that addresses what you're
cover definitionally without
representative Corman yeah how do you
like that change
um I feel like it's missing something
because
the the
current wording talks about the the
places that existed already and are
being added on to and I think what
representative Bernardi is omitting is
the idea that there was already
something existing that got added on to
and what we want is just the part that
got added on to something existing I
think we need to note that there was
well then you could add after a new
construction where I struck out the
comma and the word r
two
current
facilities
the r comma
where that struck out
new construction
line 18.
construction comma R so strike the comma
and the r
after the word construction two current
facilities
or two existing facilities or existing
facilities yep
chairman
Mr representative Harrington yeah this
is this sentence is already almost six
lines long which obviously opens it up
to all sorts of problems when you start
doing it this is this is reminiscent of
the NRC they used to do they actually
had some that were a page long one
sentence and uh leave it the way it is
put the clarifying statement next to it
separate it's clear people will
understand it it won't be we're going to
we can interpret this over and over
again and we're still going to have a
very very long sentence that can be
confused if we try to add more to it I
think just a separate sentence it was
suggested earlier would take care of the
problem
or his change suggested changes would
shorten the sentence quite a bit
I think what we're trying to clarify is
what the incremental sources are right
so we should probably split the sentence
there and just put in the definition
um put in the definition of new and then
put a period after previously existed
and start a new sentence that says
incremental electric energy sources and
Define that clearly and then if you want
to add the other sentence that's great
but I just think having it all together
makes it a little muddy and and to the
original point there were two points I
think one was that we want to make the
distinction that incremental electric
sources are those that are constructed
at the site of an existing Source but
will only be considered in terms of the
additional energy
um that will be added and I think there
were some folks that had uh opposition
to that language because we did have
that in there at one point and then the
other question that came up in this
paragraph Was on or after is it is it
supposed to be in 2023 backward looking
or is it supposed to be something that
is launching new and add-on facilities
that will be created in the future and
should the date be further in the future
like
2024 2025 so I think those are the two
things we should also be considering
here
okay
oh I would like to see this paragraph
written out so that I could see
my my copy of the amendment is now so
marked up
that I can't really make this paragraph
do you have an online copy of this in a
minute yet
and
they did send out in order to discussed
before
the purposes of this section
foreign
interesting question as I'm copying this
out
on line 16 it says on or after January
1st 2023 at a site where no facility
previously existed
well what if
the bow plant maribak wants to tear down
the existing site and then put up a new
hydroelectric Hydro hydrogen generation
station would that be precluded by this
language
because they're being built on an
it would
that's a good question so I I think what
this which is what this language is
so maybe the sentence should just end
okay
and then a new sentence would start
incremental
as a result of construction on or after
January 1st 2023 at an existing site
are capable of providing
of
so is that the right date for this
paragraph
foreign
as a result of new construction after
well all of these dates here basically
make this bill retroactive to the
beginning of this year right
so anything that's already been proposed
or
I don't know but
obviously the intent of the bill is to
make them
eligible
on or after dinner first in there yes on
no
so I missed that little side discussion
do we put
um
capable of providing additional energy
into the iso regional market into this
sentence too of this period yep it ends
after market period capable of providing
additional
Magic
period
okay
so this paragraph would Now read
for the purposes of this section new
electric energy sources are those that
are able to provide additional energy
into the iso regional market ISO New
England regional market that first began
commercial operation on or after 1-1
2023 period
incremental energy sources are those
that as a result of new construction on
or after 1 123 are capable of providing
you're at a period after energy or are
we adding into the iso New England
regional market
aftermarket yeah oh so you don't want
you do want that okay yeah I think so
so
yeah I think that's necessary regional
market
yes
yeah
and then the period yeah okay I'm good
with that
said do what we what we think needs to
all right so let's
Let's do an inventory of the number of
changes we need here
so the first change would be on page one
line 21 change May to Shell
okay
age one wine
21.
second change would be
lines eight
basically fourteen through nineteen line
eight
only
okay and so we're moving the word only I
didn't write this down because we it was
tentative at the time the word only
moves uh between the words four and up
I think I think only is good there I
like it actually that's I think that's a
good point representative Christian I
think we can do out do away with the
word only altogether
without changing the meaning
all right so line two is only
delete
okay
sure
okay Third change is lines
and that's a rewrite
that we talked about just a minute ago
Mr exchange is on line 36.
page two
line 36.
where we're going to add
creates or
with a lowercase s on supports
to that sentence correct
yep
line
four
delete
add
with to be in the best interest of rate
flavors
and then
the seventh change will be on page three
line 15 when we insert the word there
thank you
to all their distribution repairs okay
yeah
insert
there
between
clearer
I would think it would be yeah
yeah I don't think it hurts to leave it
there
okay that's seven changes that we need
made to this
can I suggest one more little grammar
change
on page okay representative Christian go
ahead on page two lines 36 and 37
um make it winter cold events
and also put a hyphen between long and
duration
say that again please
um line 37 cold events should be plural
and there should be a hyphen between
.
um okay representative munz you had
something to
yeah I guess I wanted to ask if it would
be possible to ask a few questions and
maybe there's some additional changes
that we might want to make based on the
answer of those questions shoot okay
um I
I want to come back to the winter cold
event I I guess I don't understand why
we wouldn't change that to
weather related event so that it
encompasses both winter and summer heat
wave events they both put a stress both
and that's going to become even more
significant as more and more people have
air conditioning
well ISO New England has stated that New
England is becoming a winter peaking
region rather than a summer peaking
region
so I think the original intent of the
language here was to
make sure that there would be adequate
energy available
during the winter peaking season
I thought I had seen some information
that suggested there was the opposite
that there was becoming more of a summer
phenomena than a winter phenomenon it is
already
that is the current situation but we
have heard testimony from isono England
okay personally opposed to changing this
to
to taking out the word winter and cold
and just say long duration weather
events that's what that's what I would
propose
oh
seven
yes line 37 essentially change duration
winter cold events to
and
and then
um
forgive me if I'm not up on all of the
definitions but there's two terms that
just keep that jump out at me
and I wonder if they have established
definitions one is environmental
attributes
and the second is prudently incurred
costs
like I could I could give you my own
interpretation of what that means what
they could mean but if it's already a
defined term then you know so be it
I might be able to help on that Mr
chairman yes please do yeah prudently
incurred costs as a common term used
with the puc and it's well understood
what that means it's been litigated in
courts and everything else it's it's one
of those terms that can be could mean a
lot of things to a lot of people but
it's very specific to the puc and how
they do it so Does it include uh profit
margin or rate of return calculation
well in this case we're talking about
costs right not profit okay so it would
be this is basically going to be a
pass-through contract right so they're
going to have costs associated with
they're going to have to drop the
contract they're going to have to
monitor all those are if if it's to have
a a big dinner for people that sign the
contract that's not prudently incurred
but if it's just to manage the contract
and it's prudently incurred it is yeah
that's well defined within the PMC and
that and that's utilities that that to
me is what it should be so I mean if
that's the definition that's fine what
about what about uh environmental
attributes environmental attributes I
think are just the two words is what
they say environmental attributes that's
there's no specific legal connotation
with that there's no it's not a defined
term in the jargon of Public Utilities
it simply means attributes that have to
do with the environment and it's not
depending would defined than that yeah
and because I mean one of the you know
my when I initially read this I said oh
okay what they're what they're going to
look at is for example the amount of
land or footprint of a facility so that
if it's a large solar farm that is a
hundred acres
that may or may not be a a disqualifying
factor or the pollution that it could be
generated by that facility and I just
wanted to make sure that that's what
we're talking about because I think
we're creating an opportunity here where
those are things that could be
considered
for 17 and 18 I should say
it talks about environmental attributes
comma such as renewable energy credits
comma
yeah but that's not exclusive that's
just an example I mean if we're if we're
talking about renewable energy credits
why don't we save renewable energy
credits so Mr below since you
on which do you think it's clear enough
for the purposes of this bill
or do you think it needs further
definition and please come up to the
microphone and give us your answer thank
you
um I I don't believe I was the author of
environmental attributes
um per se that that's language that came
over from the Senate
um I did suggest adding the the uh
language you suggested at line
um 18 such as renewable energy credits
which just helps it more tangible uh I
think in New England those are presently
considered perhaps the only
environmental attribute that is traded
or has a value
um in theory there could be others
um uh there is for instance uh
in in the fuel industry there there's
some environmental attributes attributed
to renewable natural gas for instance
um that that is uh called Ren's so that
that would be another type uh of
environmental attribute
um uh that's traded on at the federal
level
um but there's not too much overlap at
this point with the electric sector but
it's just just another example of an
environmental attribute that there is a
market for
so the question is can we use that
language in environmental attribute
without defining it somewhere
um I I think so I think it's generally
understood uh that uh renewable energy
credits are an environmental attribute
um I I think would be okay to substitute
uh renewable energy credits where you
use the term environmental attribute but
but there is the potential
that there could be uh other uh
environmental attributes that are
attributed to generation in the future
okay thank you so does the
representative muns does that satisfy
your question
um
not really
um I mean I I thought what the intent of
this bill was was to create a as it came
over from the Senate was to create a
technology neutral kind of environment
and
you know in you know so in instead of I
mean there's one instance where I think
it's on
let me just give you a specific
reference
no it's in a couple places but just let
me if it shows up first in line on page
um
and you know it talks about multi-year
agreements for energy in conjunction
with or independent of any attendant
environmental attributes from electric
energy sources and you know I I thought
it would be much clearer
if we said something along the lines of
um enter into multi-year agreements for
electricity to be defrost derived from
any electric energy source regardless of
the source of fuel or the means by which
such energy is produced
because I think that's what we're trying
Mr chairman can I respond go ahead so I
think the section that we're in is about
what happens in terms of how the rate
payers are going to be treated in this
purchase power agreement right so the
section is modifying what the Public
Utilities Commission is going to
consider and approve in terms of trying
to bring the best rate deal and so the
environmental attributes are
are an economic attribute of certain
types of energy and what it's what it's
asking is that
those attributes it's if you go on on
Section Five there on line 17 on page
three
to the extent any proposed agreement to
purchase electric uh energy includes
environmental attributes such as a
renewable energy credit the Public
Utilities Commission shall approve how
such environmental attributes are used
or disposed of in a manner expected to
minimize costs and maximize benefits to
ratepayers so they're saying that
attribute has a value that value needs
to be distributed to the rate payers so
that they benefit from that attribute
that's all it's saying it's it's not
talking about attributes in the abstract
it's talking about attributes in terms
of the value they can bring
um
through the contract to the people who
are ultimately paying for it I guess
then I would just go back to and let's
Mr chairman comment
go ahead getting back to the original
environmental attributes I'm I'm not
clear what this even says on page one
line seven and eight it talks about
signing agreements in conjunction with
or independent of any environmental
attributes so what does that mean you
can either take them into consideration
if you want to or you don't have to if
you don't want to it's saying
right but so what is what does that tell
you that it's it's in other words if the
puc is looking at that contract they go
like oh this contract has environmental
uh attributes this contract doesn't so
it really doesn't make any difference
because either one is acceptable
according to the law so I don't think it
says anything it doesn't give any
guidance to the puc one way or the other
if we just want to say fuel neutral or
something there but this in conjunction
with or independent of is like saying
yeah if you have environmental
attributes that's fine but if you don't
that's fine too so you know I'm looking
here as a former puc commissioner
looking at that saying that gives me no
guidance on what to do yeah again I
think it was what what this was trying
to get at in in a kind of cute way was
fuel neutral that what we're saying is
you're allowed to enter into
multi-purchase multi-year Power purchase
agreements for power from any fuel
source
there might there might be another
interpretation of this language and that
is
that you can one of these ppas could
be for Just Energy
or it could include energy and
renewable energy certificates Rex
such as the Burgess power biopower PPA
it includes energy and wrecks
and I think that's what this language is
trying to say is that these purchase
power agreements can include energy
and or wrecks
that's what I think I think
representative McGee had the the right
way to say it where there's an economic
aspect to the environmental attributes
they actually have economic value that's
that's what we mean by environmental
attributes I don't know if that needs to
be specified in the language here or if
that's understood
no I I think representative McGee's
explanation of SEC the lines you know
unpaid on page two it makes perfect
sense it's just why do we just say that
why are we dancing around it and using
that is a reasonable question that I
don't have any answer to because this is
the way it came over to us from the
Senate well I mean as Mr below said
there might be environmental attributes
uh we have a couple of people who like
to comment come on up guys
sure thanks to the committee for letting
me come up here to offer some
clarification this is in fact focused on
the environmental attributes with an
economic value and the reason to not
include specifically renewable energy
credits is because of the existence of
other environmental attributes with
value mrbilla mentioned rinse there are
also a number of possibilities of New
Market structures in the future that
this would
Encompass so it is not meant to be an
exhaustive list of what can be included
for environmental attributes but is
meant to be flexible why don't we then
say he used the the perfect term why
don't we just change it to say economic
attributes with economic value
I think that makes it very clear that
we're talking about that and not things
like
how big the plant is
well I think the reason the answer to
your question is because the puc doesn't
really concern itself that much with
those kinds of economic
decisions
I I would offer that in um environmental
attributes is a term that is commonly
used in rate making and in this Arena so
it is commonly understood to include
those
okay
my next issue you can
um and since we have some
representatives from doe maybe they can
answer the question why is it January
1st 2023
I do think that this was something that
was related to when the bill was
started when this process began and I
would
have to think pause more if we would
have a a issue with changing that date
to a more forward-looking
approach but it was related to when the
I do not have a position on that
I mean I I don't
you know if unless unless there's a good
reason for it I don't know why we would
make it retroactive
have it be January 1st of 2024 have it
okay
anybody feel strongly one way or the
other about that I don't have a
strong objection to changing those dates
to
so on or after upon passage this would
I don't care any date in the future
that's fine
all right so we'll change those two
dates change those two januaries to
September
yeah why not
so it's in the future
and sorry Mr chair but I've got a couple
more before you get let me write this
one down I just want to make sure that
we're talking about then changes on page
two lines 16 and 19.
yes it's gone oh that one's gone okay
that's right there's no wording but in
that paragraph
and only only in that paragraph
yeah well
yeah oh yeah 17 also but in that
paragraph we're changing January to
September
okay so that's uh page
two
16.
change
January
to September
okay what's your next problem
they're not problems Mr chair
suggestions
um
in section three on page two
um we list a number of things that the
Public Utilities Commission is going to
look at when they make their decision
which I I don't disagree with any of
them but I I think it would be
beneficial if we added added one
uh that says something along the lines
of generates Economic Development and
environmental benefits for New Hampshire
because I think you know
as much as you know we
I think one of the objectives of this
bill unspoken objectives perhaps is that
you know we try to encourage as much
development in New Hampshire as possible
and
that language would do that
it would just say that you know
basically what it would say is that if a
project comes along that it's based in
New Hampshire it would get if it had to
be compared to another project and
everything else being the same the
project in New Hampshire would get
preference
I get your point but I think it's
covered by if you turn the page and go
you've got other factors that have to be
taken into consideration here
diversification of New Hampshire's
electric energy sources that that could
happen all other factors necessary to
determine whether the agreement is just
unreasonable I think it's
it's covered adequately without making a
future further change
we're we're rapidly with eight changes
already
envisioned we're rapidly running into
the possibility that
the Senate won't agree to some of these
changes and then we'll have a a
difficult process they couldn't possibly
yeah
yeah go ahead I understand the theory
behind that but that really opens this
thing up to politics because then you're
going to have people lobbying uh whether
it be State reps or state senators
saying well they're going to build this
thing in my district and they're going
to be trying to put pressure on the puc
and we could come up in the governor's
office or whatever I think it's
something that's covered enough in the
bill but if you specifically say that
then um
I think it gets covered under the what's
best for the rate payers in New
Hampshire so if you're creating work and
stuff in New Hampshire the puc can look
at that and say okay well everything
else being equal it's better to contract
with somebody in New Hampshire as
compared to somebody in Maine but I
don't think we need to make it specific
because it just really opens up the door
with all due respect representative muns
I think maybe we'll forgo forego that
um
can't win them all
okay uh last
one more last comment last comment
um one of the stated objectives of the
bill is to
um and I want to look at the exact
language here
is to
um address Market Village Market
volatility which is harming New
Hampshire residents and businesses yet
the bill doesn't really do anything
about that because what it does is it
allows depending on what the whole
what's going on in the wholesale Market
it allows rates to be to be adjusted up
or down every year based on what's going
on in the wholesale Market
and I mean one one alternative to that
and I'm just going to throw that out
because I know that the appetite for
changes is minimal right now at 10 to
11. but one alternative to that is to
instead set up some kind of a
stabilization fund where if there is if
the wholesale Market goes way up that
money gets put into a bank and then when
the market goes down that money gets
pulled out to keep the rate stable
um I just throw that out because
um
you're still going to see spikes in the
price of electricity with the way this
is worded there's no stabilization
mechanism
I think that suggestion would
potentially run into some takings Clause
issues so
that might be a subject for a future
bill
all right are we satisfied that we have
adequate changes to make to this
amendment
so the next question is how are we going
to get this get this done
oh we have one more Amendment change to
consider go ahead representative
Harrington
foreign
it's on Future Energy prices is we know
nothing about future energy prices and
every time we try to predict the future
we're almost always wrong uh the thing I
mentioned earlier about the last two
Winters two Winters ago everyone thought
the prices were going to be lower than
they actually turned out to be last
winter everyone thought they were going
to be higher this is sort of a knee-jerk
reaction to last winter where the ever
never-ending need of legislators to do
stuff so we can go back to our
constituent and say we're doing stuff
but I think doing stuff for 10 years is
a long enough stretch because we can't
even predict three or four months in
advance as we've shown twice in a row
now
let's limit it to 10 years and things
will still get built if that's the
intent of this to bring on new new
generation because it's happening across
the country but we minimize the risk by
making it 10 years instead of 20. and
anyone who thinks they can predict
what's going to happen 20 years from now
in the energy markets uh is either a
fool or they're just confused because no
one never gets it right
so this would be page two line six
so
I'd like to hear from the Department of
energy
why the bill was written with 20 years
initially
and will it make
any kind of significant difference to
thank you so our position was 20 years
we have come to the table with that and
I think that's what we are most
comfortable with their
we we don't want to commit to any subset
of resources we don't know what kind of
resources are going to come forward for
these contracts and we we don't want to
limit that based on the long-term
potential viability 20 years is is the
common term for or at least has been the
common term for these long-term
agreements in in other states in the
region and again we don't want to limit
the types of resources that can
can apply for this
okay so there's no real hard and fast
reason why 20 years was chosen it was
just chosen to to give maximum
flexibility to these ppas
is that what I'm hearing you say
uh yes but I do want to point out that
it is it is
um it's not saying it will be a 20-year
term right it's enabling up to a 20-year
term and the length of the contract
would would be something that the
commission is going to look at when
they're evaluating these deals to find
out if something is in the public
interest
okay representative Harrington yeah just
uh you are correct in the past it has
been 20 years but over the last few
years uh as you can see by this list
these are it's gone down and a lot of
that is because for the most part I've
been told it's the actual Builders who
are saying we don't want to commit that
long because they think longer term
especially Renewables that they're going
to be more competitive in the future so
if they have a 10-year contract and they
can come back out and sign another one
10 years from now and up the price
because the market prices are going to
be going higher so I I just think the
risk could be limited by making it 10
years and you can still get stuff built
representative muns uh I I just want to
Echo what the gentleman from the doe
said I mean my experience is that
20-year power purchase Agreements are
are kind of the the norm particularly
when you're trying to do a a project
financed project where you're you're
using the power purchase agreement as
kind of your um
your collateral with the lender and that
would be my only concern that that by
limiting it to 10 years it might cut off
some potential financing that might be
available
representative Harrington the current
language says up to
20. it doesn't say it has to be 20 it
just says it can be 20. but it can be
anything between 0 and 20.
doesn't that cover just about all the
bases I mean
that allows for an up to 20-year
contract like I say no one is if you
find somebody that can predict Future
Energy prices let me know I'll invest in
their company but what I'm saying is if
you're true that this table should have
said all these other producers are not
signing 20-year contracts then isn't it
likely that anybody who does anything
under this legislation would also say no
I'm not doing 20 probably but I they
just want to make more protection to the
rate payers for not getting stuck with
something that's doesn't turn out to be
that good so suffering for 10 years
isn't as bad as suffering for 20.
yeah
what would you guys think you know um
your legislature representative
Harrington I'm certainly sensitive to
your view and and you know share it I
will say that there is going to be a
rigorous review of these from the
Department of energy the consumer
Advocate and and the commission when
they make their evaluation enabling
something up to 20 years we felt covered
the gamut of of what's traditionally
been done here and the potential
resources that could respond to a an RFP
so we wanted to be enabling knowing on
the back end there will be that that
rigorous review but um that's that's
where our approach has been
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman yeah I just I
wanted to weigh in at this point because
I
I feel as though
um
my my colleagues comments about the
future of the energy market and the
um
reducing Risk by limiting contracts to
10 years
um betrays a
they bias toward
traditional fossil fuel energy markets
when this bill started out in the Senate
it was specifically
aimed at enabling
long-term power purchase agreements for
renewable resources and it was of course
broadened to be technology neutral and
that's fine
but
as my
Democratic colleague representative muns
alluded to
particularly with Renewables the power
purchase agreement is critical
um
critical aspect of getting such a
project built and financed
circling back to the
you know comments of Representative
Harrington you know who can predict the
energy markets
20 years from now well I can predict
that the price of sunshine and wind 20
years from now will still be zero so
a project developer capitalizing a solar
farm or wind farm
and the batteries
necessary to make that that generating
asset more reliable and capable of
providing
um
you know during
Darkness during lack of sunshine wind
needs the 20-year PPA
to to finance and and again the fuel
price of those projects is going to be
zero so that's why they need the 20-year
PPA to offer into the market a stable
price for 20 years so
we if we quote reduce risk we're
actually going to as again Mike esteemed
colleague representative Harrington is
suggesting we're actually going to be
eliminating
um
some generation resources from the
market
if I could respond to it oh yes you can
go ahead first of all these are all
renewable projects they are being built
and none of them have a 20-year thing as
far as biased towards uh non-renewable
energy well when you think I'm biased on
that if not is really irrelevant look at
the iso New England queue you will not
find I think there's one
10 or 15 megawatt gas speaker in the
queue everything else is solar in wind
and battery storage so what is going to
be built is going to be renewable energy
no one is going to is talking about
putting in a new large gas plant or
anything like that so
again projects are being built and
they're they're all renewable projects
all that list that I gave you well with
1300 megawatts and they're being built
without 20-year contracts so I think if
we can minimize the risk by cutting that
back because who knows maybe maybe the
the never-ending uh story of fusion
power being uh present in the next 10
years which has been been told since I
was in Graduate School uh we'll come to
a fruition and prices will drop
substantially but the one like I say the
only thing we know about future energy
prices is we don't know anything about
future energy prices and I think 10
years is an adequate term to get the
representative Christian
thank you I just wanted to point out um
on this great list that you gave us so
although none of them are 20-year most
of them the majority of them are more
than 10 years so I think at least 15 uh
make sense given the number of 12 and 15
Mr Lakota did you have a suggestion to
make
Porter Mr chair
yes
thank you would the chair consider for
the record to uh acknowledge the
representatives DLT I don't think they
stated the name for the records Mr
Pearland and others
foreign
sure so for the record my name is Chris
selms Deputy Commissioner and I was
joined by Dan Phelan who is the
wholesale administrator for the
Department of energy thank you for doing
that
Mr locata
please tell us who you are and who you
represent
morning Michael akata eversource
um I I guess I don't have too too much
to add I would
um say that the points made about the
flexibility of the term up to 20 years
are important that that is a a
requirement for some projects to obtain
financing to have that uh long-term I
think the points about uh you know you
might reduce the number of respondents
this is already a very rigorous review
that is very focused on price and
reliability
and from the utility perspective of
issuing these rfps I think further
limitations might actually result in in
potentially a failed RFP so I I think
the points made about the importance of
keeping the flexibility of up to 20
years and then having uh as I think the
doe had stated the rigorous review on
the back end uh are are well put
based on your experience would 15 years
be long enough to to ensure the
adequate response to these rfps or does
it need to be 20. I think 20 is an
industry standard it is consistent with
other uh rfps that have been put out in
the region that is something that
developers are familiar with that they
can sort of use to to obtain their
required financing so I would suggest uh
leaving at 20.
all right I would uh representative
Harrington goes one final comment on
that
um all we have to do is look at the
Burgess biomass contract that was done
rigorously it was scrubbed every way you
possibly could the puc looked over that
for months they had hearings with a
bunch of people they had meetings this
went on for for a long time and it's
proved that it's been a disaster
financially for New Hampshire and I'm
just thinking you can have all the
different reviews and this and that you
want but you still cannot predict the
future accurately when it comes to
Energy prices so the limit on the time I
could go with 15 years it reduces the
we have 10
members of the committee here let's see
a show of hands who people from people
who want to keep it at 20 or keep people
who want to uh yeah let's do people want
okay that's eight out of ten so I think
uh maybe we'll just leave this at 20.
since it's up to 20 I think it's fairly
safe to do that
but we appreciate you bringing it up
representative Harrington
all right so now we have eight Amendment
changes that need to be made here
and uh
so we're going to need to walk this over
to OLS and get them to
work on this if we're going to have any
chance of having
a workable amendment by two o'clock this
afternoon
so I have I made the electronic changes
and I can shoot them to Christy and to
OLS
so okay
all right
so that's how we'll proceed proceed
Christy you'll take a look at her draft
I'll take a letter a look at her draft
all right
one last thing we need to do is vote as
a subcommittee on whether to accept
the new amendment that will will will
shortly be proposed that includes all
the changes that we've gone over here
and make a recommendation to the full
committee to pass Senate bills 54 by
adopting this amendment so we have four
members of the subcommittee here
if you are in favor of making that
recommendation please say I I
anybody opposed
okay four members of the subcommittee
are here and four vote affirmative
to make the recommendation to the full
committee that we adopt Senate Bill 54
move in a second
you moved it I moved it representative
thank you okay
for the purposes of the paperwork it was
moved and seconded and then we voted
four to nothing
to recommend that the full committee
adopt SB 54 as amended by a new
amendment that will be available by two
o'clock hopefully
and with that I think we're going to
shut down our activity for the moment
we'll meet back here at two o'clock to
go into executive session
there will be a majority Caucus meeting
in this room at one o'clock
so we'll need the room need the room to
ourselves at that moment
but it'll be back open by 20 minutes of
two so we'll see you all then have a
yep
we generally book it on Mondays and
Tuesdays for our group because we
have those days yeah so it should be
there I have to go get food though I
didn't bring a lunch today
yeah
there we go I'm just shooting that off
to you
um oh it says PDF I hope this worked I
opened it in word and what ends up
happening
end of covid right today isn't it May
please take your seats everyone this
meeting will start in one minute
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the afternoon session of science
technology and energy for Monday May 1st
happy May 1st to everyone
who's watching or in attendance here
this afternoon we have two tasks to
accomplish this afternoon the first task
is to pass judgment on Senate bill 54.
the second task is to all gather behind
me for a committee picture to
commemorate the end of our first year of
this biennium
so before we get to our task for today I
want to Welcome to our committee Angela
Brennan who is sitting in this afternoon
for representative McWilliams
representative Brennan Welcome to our
committee
okay so with that I'm going to open an
exact session on Senate bill 54. and I
move ought to pass as amended and
recognize representative McGee
yes I'll second that Amendment
representative McGee seconds the motion
of ought to pass as amended by
myself and I recognize representative
McGee for an amendment
yes I would like to make a motion that
we pass amendment number 2023 1586 H I
recognize representative Thomas
second it's been moved and seconded that
we resolve to pass Amendment 2023 1586 h
discussion on the amendment
um
discussion on the amendment well I would
just draw your attention to a
parenthetical phrase on line 17 page two
which uh we had intended to strike which
I would ask that we
um
figure out a way to strike whether
that's going to be once it's over the
wall or in a committee of conference
um and that would be on line 17 after
2023 rather than a comma that would be a
period and the parenthetical phrase that
would be removed is at a site where no
other than that
there were eight changes made in this
amendment to the amendment that we
worked off of in the committee work
session earlier this morning
and
we have verified that all those changes
were made
and the change that representative McGee
just suggested was an oversight on what
we submitted to OLS so I propose that we
adopt this amendment as
offered to us from OLS and we take care
of that parenthetical or that
prepositional phrase during the
committee of conference process
representative Harrington yeah just so
it's clear to everybody why we wanted to
take that out is because if we were to
repower a facility such as like the bow
plant or any other closed plant it would
already have a facility previously
existed but it's been shut down so if
you're going to repower it with some
other type of Technology you shouldn't
eliminate the plant because you may be
able to make use of parts of the plant
and certainly the transmission lines so
that's the reason for we want to get
all right further discussion on this
amendment for those of you who are not
here this morning or at our other work
sessions are there questions
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um you said there were eight eight
changes to this could you just briefly
go over them yes thank you okay so the
the utilities shall solicit public
comment previously the text said the
utilities May solicit public content
comment
the next change we made was on page two
lines
line eight excuse me line eight
where we struck the word only
which was a Superfluous word as it turns
out
and then on lines
15 through 20
we broke up a previously
awkward paragraph which contained both
definitions we broke that up into two
sentences with each definition
listed separately
we also changed the date to September
1st of 2023 it had been January 1st
but we saw no need to make it
retroactive
next
was excuse me we also changed the
wording for incremental electric energy
sources we did rewrite that yes we did
incremental energy sources that
definition we wrote that somewhat just
to make it clear that it was
just the new energy than an existing
Source produced not the entire energy
output of that source that would be
considered under this uh proposal
or this legislation
next we go down to line
36 yes
and we
added
no actually it's it led over to the next
page the first page of Page Three
the first line of Page Three we added
the words creates or
to that line so it previously read
supports Electric
energy sources we changed it to read
creates or supports electric energy
sources
and we changed winter event to weather
event
correct then we changed in line two long
duration weather long duration winter
cold events to long duration weather
events
yep
so on line four
we struck the
parenthetical phrase stop loss caps
from the language and then down to line
five
we deleted the the text
adequate and replaced it with the text
to be in the best interest of rate
payers
edit that there
yes so it is line 17 so we added the
word there between the words all and
distribution so it now reads credit or
charge all their distribution rate pairs
the difference blah blah blah
so those are all the changes that we
made to the amendment
and
in my discussions with the other members
of the committee
it seems that everyone is now satisfied
that we have done everything we can do
to make Senate Bill 54 the best Bill it
can be
but I'd like to hear other reaction from
representative muns
Mr chair in in deference to
representative uh Chariton we forgot the
The Hyphen between long and duration
well we suggested it to OLS and they
declined to accept that suggestion so
I'm going to defer to all this on that
one
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman I you guys
probably talked about it this morning
but I am happy to see from subcommittee
on page three line 12 it was changed to
shallow instead of May there
so that was probably changed before this
morning but that was a change that was
well representative Harrington yeah I
just for the record I guess I want to
say this is a I hope people realize this
is a major change that we're
contemplating here kind of uh going
stepping back a little bit too before
restructuring because now we're talking
about the utilities locking in long-term
contracts that the rate payers are going
to Bear all the responsibility for and
basically whatever risk is associated is
being born by the rate payers now there
are some Provisions in here to try to do
something but I'm not sure how you're
going to come up with a contract that is
going to be signed by A supplier for 20
years if it's not kind of like locked in
at this rate or something so I know I'll
probably vote in favor I will vote in
favor of this I just want people to
understand this is a big change and
hopefully it's something that uh you
know we try and see what happens but I'm
a little leery about going back to that
rate payer risk rather than uh the other
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you chair I agree with my
colleague to my right uh I will go into
this
agreeing to it but with some degree of
interpretation on any long-term
seeing that I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of the adoption
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes Michael Harrington
yes Troy Marner yes
John lewicki yes
he's not here
JD Bernardi yes Tom poche yes
James Summers yes Kat McGee yes
Angela Brennan yes
Jackie creation yes
lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes Henry
Noel
not here excuse me Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes mid Reynolds yes
chairman Vose yes
18-0
by account of 18 to nothing the
amendment two zero two three one five
eight six H is adopted I now move ought
to pass as amended and recognize
representative McGee yes I'd like to
second that motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
resolved to judge
Senate Bill 54 as ought to pass as
amended amended by Amendment
2023-1586 H is there any further
I will add my voice to the chorus that
says that while this bill
does not guarantee that anything good is
going to happen
it does
potentially enable the possibility that
something good could happen
and I don't see any negative or downside
to this bill so I will be happy to
support it and I hope everyone on the
committee will join me any further
discussion representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman
um
notwithstanding the
trepidation expressed by
my two colleagues to your right
um I am going to support the bill I'm
glad we all seem to be supporting the
bill because in my view
the purpose of this bill is to enable
uh
the largest buyers of electricity in the
state that is our three regulated
utilities
to get into the business of Contracting
over the long term
for renewable energy resources whose
fuel cost is zero so
I don't share their concern uh
that my colleagues expressed about
you know the past experiences and
long-term contracts where contracts
would be signed and then of course
fossil fuel prices would drop
and saddle rate payers with uh you know
higher than Market costs the fuel costs
of the renewable resources that I expect
will benefit from this legislation are
zero
now and forever and so
um I expect the result of this
legislation to be that we pull a lot
more
substantial sized renewable energy
resources into the supply
for our New Hampshire rate payers to
everyone's benefit
thank you further discussion from the
committee
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of ought to
Doug Thomas yes Janine otter yes Michael
Harrington yes Troy murner yes John
lewicki yes JD Bernardi yes Tom poche
yes James Summers yes Kat McGee yes
Angela Brennan yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris munz yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Ned
Reynolds yes chairman Rose yes 18-0
by a vote of 18 to nothing the committee
resolves
to send House Bill 54 to the floor of
the house with a recommendation of ought
to pass as amended
amended by 2023 1586 h
I want to thank you all and with that
I'll close the executive session Mr
chair
it does have an F in on it
let's just put it on the regular
hopefully it'll be a Voice vote all
right with that before we suspend our
activity today for the day I would like
to ask all members of the committee to
come up here and stand beside behind
myself uh representative Thomas
and representative Bernardi we will
remain sitting and Christy if you could